[MUSIC PLAYING]
FREDERIK G. PFERDT: Welcome
to a very creative afternoon
and an Authors AtGoogle Talk.
My name is Frederik.
Please join me in welcoming
David and Tom Kelley.
[APPLAUSE]
FREDERIK G. PFERDT: They've
just published recently a book,
"Creative Confidence: Unleashing
the Creative Potential
Within Us All."
And I actually had the
pleasure of having lunch
with Tom and David.
And David asked me, I
think the second question,
so what are we going to do here?
Google is already very creative.
So let us come back to
that question later on.
So, Tom, you published
various books
around innovation, "The
Art of Innovation,"
"The Ten Faces of Innovation,"
bestselling books.
TOM KELLEY: Uh, huh.
FREDERIK G. PFERDT: So what
motivated you to really publish
this book around
creative confidence now?
TOM KELLEY: Sure.
So this book is actually quite
different than my other books.
It focuses more
on the individual.
It's more about creativity
per se and stuff like that.
So it has a business
audience, but it actually
speaks to a broader audience.
So we're a "New York Times"
bestseller as of two days ago.
And it's not in the
business category.
It's in the advice category,
which is quite different.
But why'd I write this book?
And really, the answer is,
you know, two chairs away
from me is my brother.
Back in 2007, David was sick.
David had throat cancer.
And they only gave him a
40% chance of survival.
And, wow, in that situation,
you confront a lot of demons,
you know.
And that was hanging over
our heads for a long time.
I spent most of the
year with him in '07.
And after chemo and radiation,
and eventually surgery,
toward the end of the year,
at least a possibility arose,
became more tangible, that
he was going to survive,
And, you know, you
can see, he's there.
That's the answer
six years later,
And so we had talked
about the future all year.
And so late in
2007, then we did.
We felt like we had permission
to talk about the future.
And so as we did that, we made
two promises to each other.
David and I have worked
together for almost 30 years.
And the two promises
were, one, that we
would take a trip together.
Because, oddly, we have never
traveled together as adults.
Our big trip was in 1967.
We drove from Ohio to
California, you know,
the promised land.
And so in our work
at IDEO, if one of us
goes to a meeting
in Grand Rapids
or wherever, the other one
doesn't have to go, right?
And so we don't travel together.
So promise number one is
to do a trip together.
And that became this really
fun trip to Tokyo and Kyoto,
two places that I really like.
And, oh, I got to pick.
So I picked.
But then, the other
promise was that we
would do a project together.
David and I are not
very good at leisure.
You know, we're couldn't
just hang out for some months
together or play
golf or I don't know.
Just not in our DNA.
And so if you want to
spend time together,
you got to think of something
to work on together.
And so we said
we'd do a project.
And at that time we didn't
know what the project would be.
But the project became a book.
It became the book called
"Creative Confidence" that
is sitting right there.
DAVID KELLEY: Yeah,
I actually highly
recommend being diagnosed
with a terminal disease.
Just--
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID KELLEY: --don't
get a terminal disease.
But if you could fake
yourself into really believing
that for a while, it's
kind of cathartic.
It'll straighten you right up.
You'll do all kinds
of different things.
[LAUGHTER]
FREDERIK G. PFERDT:
Speaking of different things
you did in your life,
David, you founded
a very successful
company called IDEO.
You also started an educational
institution called the Stanford
d.school.
So you also started a
revolution around innovation
and innovators in general
and using design thinking
as a framework to really
push that forward.
Can you speak a
little bit about what
you have learned
throughout the years,
about innovation in general
but also about innovators?
DAVID KELLEY: Yeah.
Well, you know, I
mean, we think of IDEO
as a successful company, you
know, as this little thing.
When you come here, and it
would fit in one cafeteria,
it doesn't feel that big a deal.
There's a couple things.
So one, I'm really
proud of IDEO.
You know, you get a
bunch of designers
together and then give them a
really difficult problem-- you
know, fix the educational
system in Peru,
or improve the experience of
checking into the Mayo Clinic,
or whatever-- and they come
up with really wonderful,
new to the world,
viable solutions.
And that feels really good.
And at the d.school--
d.school's successful
beyond my wildest
dreams-- and you
see people flip from
thinking of themselves
as not creative to thinking
of themselves as creative.
And it impacts
their entire life,
the number of people
that kind of come to me
and say, this thing's changed
my life, as an educator,
it feels great, especially
since for the first kind of 20
years of my academic career,
I was the design guy.
So when somebody important
in the university
came to see me,
they wanted to know,
where did you get those shoes,
or where I get cool glasses,
you know?
Now, they're coming
with strategic questions
about what's the future
of higher education,
and can we work on that?
So I'm just saying it surprised
me and it's really exciting.
We could go on
and on about that.
But if you just want to think
about the highlights of what
we found, the first
thing is that being
human-centered results
in new innovation.
So if you think that there's
lots of companies and people
working on coming up
with new business ideas
and then trying to understand
how people might accept them.
And then, there's lots of people
coming up with technology ideas
and trying to figure out how
the business side of that
might work and how
people might accept that.
And we found that, for
us, for design types,
the best approach is to
come in from the human side,
like what do people value,
what's meaningful for people,
and then go out and try to
find technologies and business
solutions to those problems.
So that seems to be, for
us, the number one thing.
This empathy for people is the
best way to lead to innovation.
And the other thing
is that this is
a team sport, this innovation.
I mean, there's the lone genius.
I mean, if you've got Leonardo
da Vinci on your team,
you're set, you know.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID KELLEY: But if
you don't, then it's
really important to have
a team that's very diverse
and that they work together.
They have had
different experiences.
And they have different
points of views.
And then, if you can get them
to work together and build on
each other's ideas rather
than just kind of show
how smart you are
by saying what's
wrong with the
other person's idea,
if you can get to build on them.
And what happened
at the d.school,
I believe-- lots of things
happened at the d.school--
but the thing I
believe is that we'd
been trying to do
multidisciplinary stuff
at the university for a
long time but, you may know,
if you've been in a university,
that it's the opposite of that.
It's in deep silos.
And people are
winning Nobel Prizes.
And I would hope that they
would keep doing that.
I'm not trying to talk
people out of going deep.
I think that's very important.
But we kind of miss things
in between these deep silos
of knowledge.
And so what we found is
that by having people
from different disciplines, you
get to these kind of big ideas
that are between
disciplines by using methods
like design thinking and
having these diverse teams that
can build on each other.
So that's the basic
thing that's happened.
FREDERIK G. PFERDT: You
both write in your book
that you want to make
the world a better place
through embracing creative
confidence in our lives.
At Google, we have
a similar mission
on making the world a better
place through technology.
So where do you
see the parallels
in what you're trying
to achieve and what
we're trying to achieve
with technology.
TOM KELLEY: Sure.
I mean, those two are not in
conflict in any way, right?
What we're seeing is this
trend, this kind of maker trend,
that we've experienced both
in our teams and in the world
at large, in which
new technologies put
creative tools in
everybody's hands.
You know, there's that old line
about, in the 20th century,
kids watch TV.
In the 21st century,
kids make TV.
I think they're
talking about YouTube
when they say that, right?
And so I think the
two go hand in hand.
I mean, we just
maybe approach it
from a slightly
different direction.
But one of the things that
we've latched on to early on
is a year or two ago there
was an Adobe study called
"State of Create,"
in which they, you
know, with an interest
not unlike yours--
they want to use technology
to help people in their focus
on creativity-- and so they
ask 5,000 people in five
different countries
about their beliefs
surrounding creativity--
one about the link
between creativity and
economic development.
And 80% of people
said, unlocking
creativity is critical to
economic development, which
we thought was great.
But really interesting was
the follow-on question.
And they said,
well, how about you?
How about you as an individual?
Do you have a chance to live
up to your creative potential?
In other words, do
you have a chance
to bring your
whole self to work?
And across the world, only 25%
of the people said yes to that.
And so we think
it's a worthy goal.
I mean, it's a worthy
question, for us and for you,
of how might we
unlock the creativity
of the other 75%, right?
And so you might
approach that question
from a slightly different
direction than us.
But I think we're
both quite interested
in how to change the
world in that way.
DAVID KELLY: You just
have 42,000 people on it.
We have five.
[LAUGHTER]
FREDERIK G. PFERDT:
So coming back
to that question, so how
would you actually recommend
organizations going
about unlocking
the potential of creative
people in their organizations?
DAVID KELLEY: Yeah.
I'm not sure this applies
to Google, as I said before,
but what we find is that
you have to have support
from the top of the company
that the experiments are allowed
to happen.
But it's all really
about small experiments.
It's all about starting a
bunch of little brush fires
in different places
in the company
and hoping that
they kind of, you
know, catch on
and grow together.
So we, in all of our
exec eds at the d.school,
from the minute the people
come to go through our program
and learn our
methods and stuff, we
focus on what are they going
to do when they get back?
I mean, how do you
implement when you get back,
and how are you going to
protect these ideas and stuff?
Because one of the
things, and early on,
is that people would have
this cathartic experience.
Then they'd go back.
And the mass of the place,
the habit of the place
they were going to,
was just too extreme
for them to catch hold, right?
And so we spend a
lot of time trying
to understand how
you kind of come up
with these ideas in a
way that can be accepted
by the rest of the organization.
TOM KELLEY: Yeah.
You know, in cultures there's
a really important moment we've
discovered.
And I personally have worked
with 1,500 clients, and David,
I'm sure, a lot more.
And there's a really
important moment
in which a not yet perfect
idea gets put on the table.
And people look
really closely to see
how do leaders
especially react to that.
You know, you've probably
heard those stories
about the tyrant boss who, you
bring in the unfinished thing,
and they say, how
would our organization
be worse if you weren't
here tomorrow, you know,
that kind of, like,
get out of my office,
because you haven't thought
through every detail
of this idea yet.
But in great cultures,
in creative cultures,
the first instinct is
to build on the idea.
There's a skill
we call squinting,
in which you ignore
the surface details
and you look at the
shape of the idea
and try to figure out how
could you make it better.
And if the leaders of an
organization are squinters,
you know, are the
kind of people who
look past the
surface details, what
we found is, there's a better
idea flow within the company.
More ideas come up, because
you don't have to self-edit.
You don't have to wait
until your idea is perfect.
You bring it out in
its embryonic form
and say, well, I'm thinking
about this, because you're
allowed to kind of think
out loud about things.
You know, here in the Valley,
ask any venture capitalist,
and they will tell you that
all other things equal,
the VC firm with
the better deal flow
wins, right, because they're
picking from 1,000 instead
of picking from
five possibilities.
And so we think it's true
with companies with idea flow.
If you're the kind of company--
and I know that in many ways
you are-- if you're the kind
of company in which ideas get
circulated all of the time--
and many fall by the wayside,
because they're not yet perfect
or because they don't pan out--
you still have this rich
culture of ideas to choose from.
What we found is that those
are the companies that
succeed and sustain
in the long run.
FREDERIK G. PFERDT:
So let's move
from an organizational level
to an individual level.
I think that's very interesting.
So what prevents,
actually, people
for having those
creative breakthroughs?
So is there a routine,
especially like if, maybe, you
have a personal routine you
want to share about David
or David wants to
share about Tom,
like how you actually
train the creative muscle,
if that's even possible.
So some people do meditation,
and they would go work out.
So what are you doing?
DAVID KELLEY: Well, again--
I don't know about Google
and that it makes sense
now about Google--
but what's really going
on in these people that
aren't confident in
their creative ability
is something happened to
them when they were kids,
and they opted out of thinking
of themselves as creative.
They think of themselves only
as analytical, which is fine.
We're not saying
don't be analytical.
We're saying be
creative, as well.
And so what happens
is they develop
this fear of kind
of owning an idea.
Like you don't want to
be the person who came up
with that idea, because then
as it goes through the company,
and if it doesn't work, then
you are labeled with that idea.
So it's that kind of
fear of being judged.
And so, I mean,
whatever it is-- I mean,
I don't understand Google's
culture-- but whatever it is,
there's fears that
can be alleviated
by this process we
call guided mastery.
And some of you may
have seen my TED Talk.
I talked about this
guy that I really
kind of got to
enjoy at Stanford.
His name is Albert Bandura.
If you're a psychology major,
you know who Albert Bandura is.
He's like the most cited
psychologist in the world,
living.
Freud probably has more
citations somewhere.
And when I met
him, he was talking
about this kind
of curing phobias.
Now, lots of people
that we run into
have this fear of being judged.
And it turns out, it's
the same deal as far as
how you get around
it, how you change
the way you think of
that, of yourself.
And so he was curing
snakes and spiders
phobias and stuff like that.
And the way he did it, in this
thing called guided mastery,
is he takes people through
a series of small steps,
you know, baby steps.
And each one, they're
successful at it.
So you're looking at the
snake through the mirror.
And then 15 steps
later, you're standing
at the door, your
hand being held.
Then you get to
a welder's glove.
And eventually, you
touch the snake.
But there's a guy who's got a
near 100% cure rate of people
with these kind of phobias.
And they've had these
phobias their whole lives,
and they're not going
outside or going on a hike
because there might
be a snake there.
And he can cure them
through this guided mastery.
So what we feel, when you
talk about the individual,
we know, at the d.school
and IDEO, anyplace,
if we take people who have
this fear of being judged
or of failing or whatever
in the workplace,
and we can take them through
a series of successes--
we give them a small
project just like when
you were at the d.school.
You know, we have
a small project
that you can be
somewhat successful at.
And then we increase the
complexity and the scope
and the team size and
all of that stuff.
And it's not that long,
after a few projects,
that you're thinking, oh, my,
god, I am a creative person.
So for the book, we interviewed
100 people, most of them
from the d.school,
and just talking
about their extraordinary
transformation
by gaining this feeling in
their bodies of being creative.
And so it's pretty
amazing to watch
how this can be transformative
to the individual.
FREDERIK G. PFERDT:
You spoke a little bit
about this beginner's
mind or child's mind,
and you quoted, I
think, a lot of times,
that you should really embrace
that in everything you're
doing.
So what would you actually
recommend for parents then?
Because I saw that in
your book, you also
dedicate your book
to your parents.
What would you recommend--
that's the first question
for you-- for parents, what
they should do with their kids?
But secondly, how
did your parents
influence you
throughout your lives?
TOM KELLEY: Sure.
You know, this
parenting thing is hard,
as you've probably noticed.
Those kids don't come
with instruction sets.
It's sometimes hard
to know, is this
where I'm supposed to be firm?
Is this where I'm supposed to
be laissez-faire, or whatever?
But just think
about our parents.
It wasn't that they were
artists or something.
It wasn't that they got out
the finger paints with us
every day.
It was that they give us a
lot of space to do things,
that they weren't
quick to judge us
or to kind of reign us in
when we got a little creative.
You know, David and
I took a lot of stuff
apart as kids, including
the family piano.
And many of those things
never went back together.
A piano, once you
take it apart, it's
actually kind of beautiful.
Those 88 hammers, David's
got those up on his wall.
But nobody ever played
that piano afterwards.
And the parents
never complained.
And so I think it's
just kind of permission
to misbehave a little bit,
permission to be creative.
And you have this sort
of nurturing environment
that says, and it's still
going to be OK, right?
And so that's really what
our parents did for us.
And that's what I've
tried to do for my kids.
DAVID KELLEY: It could be
called benign neglect, right?
So we got away with it.
The one I remember
the most, or that I've
been told the most it
was hardest to take, was,
so, I was 12.
I got a brand new
red Schwinn bicycle.
You can imagine,
that's a big gift.
We're, you know, relatively
not that well-heeled a family.
And so a Schwinn
bike was a big deal.
And somehow the next day I
took it out and sandblasted it
and painted it
fluorescent green.
And so, I can imagine,
that was a little hard
to look the other way.
TOM KELLEY: Well, speaking
of fluorescent green, so, OK,
that was David's bike.
And so it's kind of his to
do whatever he wanted to.
But he came home from college--
he went to Carnegie Mellon
as an undergrad-- and he came
home from college freshman
year, and he got four
shades of green paint,
including fluorescent
green, and painted a stripe,
like four feet high
and 40 feet long,
against the back
wall of the house.
And you can imagine a parent
in a small town in Ohio
being not sure
about that, right?
But that green stripe's still
there all these years later.
DAVID KELLEY: Yeah,
you're mostly too young.
But this was the era of
super graphics, right?
FREDERIK G. PFERDT: So
what changed about David?
[LAUGHTER]
TOM KELLEY: You can Google that.
FREDERIK G. PFERDT: Great.
What changed about David
over the years, then?
You spoke about when he was 12.
But what's really now when
you say, oh, David, that's
really why you're
childlike, not childish?
TOM KELLEY: Sure.
So there's that great
quote from Picasso.
He says, every
child is an artist,
and the challenge is to remain
an artist after you grow up.
So David and I were
quite different as kids.
And the thing about David
is he had indication,
there were tells even
as a small child,
that he was going
to be creative,
that he was going to become a
designer one day or something,
whereas I was the opposite.
You couldn't have
spotted it in me.
And so I think that--
for a lot of you,
you might have fit David's
pattern more as kids--
but the fact that I could
cross over that line,
I think is good news for lots
of people out in the business
community and beyond.
Because I wanted to be a
lawyer, for God's sake.
What was I thinking?
I'm not sure.
I got the GMAT,
abandoned that, but got
an MBA, worked for
an accounting firm,
worked five years doing
spreadsheets-- first
by hand, because we didn't have
those computer things, and then
on the early laptop
machines-- and so
at age 35, no
indication, right, that I
was going to have a chance
to have a creative life.
And so this is good news.
Because you can decide today.
You can change later in life.
And so I just basically
immersed myself
in the creative
environment at IDEO
and gained creative
confidence in that process.
And so, you know, yeah, you
could spot the stuff in David,
but, yeah, hard to tell
in some of the rest of us.
FREDERIK G. PFERDT:
So two more questions.
And then, I want to open
it up for the Googlers
to ask questions to you.
The first one is, when you
think about what's next--
so in the next
five to 10 years--
I think that's a time
frame we as Googlers think,
like it's way in the
future, but it's still
something you can
somehow guess what's
going on-- so what
are your plans?
You started a
successful company.
You started a successful
educational institution.
You wrote various books
really successfully.
So what's next?
TOM KELLEY: You know, I bet
David's got his own answer.
But for me, this book
is out, and it's done,
and books are so hard.
I'm not sure I'm
doing another one.
So the idea is out
in the world now.
But I feel like it's got a
pretty long run, this idea
of creative confidence,
that dealing with the 75%.
And so I've been
working on innovations,
you know, the
products, the services,
the digital experiences
for 30 years.
And I was thinking,
the next decade
or so, that I would focus
more, or at least as much,
on innovators, on inspiring
individuals-- especially
early in their
careers, because they
have so much promise
coming up-- to get
in touch with their
creative confidence
so they can make a bigger
impact on the world
and have more fun at work.
You know, we did
those 100 interviews.
And it is so much fun to
be around those people who
have gained creative
confidence basically
around the fourth
grade, a lot of them.
And it happens for
kids a lot there.
They decided they
weren't creative,
and their world gets smaller
when they make that decision.
They kind of opt out of stuff.
And then, everybody we
interviewed, everybody-- and it
wasn't a random sampling
of the universe.
We sought them out-- but all
100 of the people we interviewed
had decided at some point
that they were creative.
And, wow, just the
look in their eyes.
They're fun to be around.
And in the process, it's
stuff isn't even limited
by creativity.
They are taking on
bigger challenges.
They are more resilient
in the face of obstacles,
more perseverance.
They're just cool.
I mean, they're just
fun to be around.
DAVID KELLEY: Yeah.
So for me, it's about
scaling this thing.
So some really interesting
challenges with scaling.
It seems like scaling
keeps coming up
as the problem everywhere.
And for us, even if I
just look at Stanford,
the university would
like every student
to have that as a
trait, that they're
confident in their
creative ability,
that Stanford is known as
a place where the kids have
that confidence and they
use that tool all the time.
Just that alone,
how do you know?
There's a few
thousand students who
go through d.school,
maybe, a year--
but how do you get to
the a large percentage
of a university?
And it's the same way
with the relationships
we have with other outside
universities and stuff.
And, also, my main focus,
as a kind of a second thing,
is K-12 education.
And so we're doing things.
Like, in Peru, we're
trying to understand
how to change all of
Peru's educational system
because it's particularly bad.
And then, OK, how does
that apply to the US?
Because the US
thing-- we've been
working in K-12 for a
while-- and as I told you
about the brush fire problem-- p
we got a few brush fires going,
but nothing's that big a deal.
And so trying to
scale by seeing what
we can do as the
different experiments
and then how you scale them.
And so we're making progress.
I mean, there's lots
of good news out there.
But I don't think we've
found that kind of cleverness
about what makes
something really
scale, especially in K-12.
FREDERIK G. PFERDT: So
Googlers in general, I think,
are really passionate
about working
on big, audacious goals.
So what would be one big,
audacious goal or problem
for you which a lot of people
should actually work on
in the next three or four years?
DAVID KELLEY: Well, I
don't know if you know.
I've been going to TED
for 20 years or so.
And the biggest, the most
watched TED Talk is Ken
Robinson's.
And in that, he said that
he thought in schools,
creativity was as
important as literacy.
And we're a long way
from believing that.
But I really think that through
technology and through doing
things like project-based
learning and stuff,
I think that's the
audacious goal.
I mean, there's
plenty of other ones.
But from my perspective,
or from our perspective,
and the same thing at
Stanford, how do you
get creative confidence into as
many kids as you possibly can?
Because when we do
succeed, you just
see how it's transformative.
TOM KELLY: Yeah, and for
me I would say the big goal
would be cracking the
code on behavior change.
You know, so much of what we
do, all of our social innovation
work, and even our work
in health care and things
like that, we're trying
to change behavior
of the constituents
that matter to us.
They're not always
customers, even.
And that's really hard.
People cling to
their old patterns
even when their old patterns
aren't the best for them.
And so, for example,
I did a work
with the water in
developing countries.
We're in India
trying to get people
to drink the safe water,
the filtered water,
the water that won't
make them sick.
But they've been drinking that
other water for generations.
And so the old way to do that,
the attempted behavior change
approach to that, is you send a
social worker into the village,
and they talk about the
germ theory of disease,
you know, fascinating
stuff, right?
And they're explaining
why you shouldn't really
drink that water from the
well, at least untreated.
You should get this other
water, which is not free, right?
Now, we're talking
about families
for whom any new expense means
trading off something else.
They're living very
close to the Earth.
And so they'll be there, really,
with their best interests
at heart, trying to
convince this community
to go for the safe water.
And then, someone
will raise their hand.
And apparently it
happens a fair amount.
Someone will raise their
hand and says something like,
well, you know, my mother
gave me water from that well.
You're not saying my
mom is wrong, are you?
And if you're that social worker
in that little village in India
and that question
comes up, I would
urge you to just
leave immediately.
There is no beating
that question.
You're not going
to change behavior
in that village that day.
Because we're very
conscious, we're
hiring behavioral
economists, we're
very interested in this
behavior change, what
we do is we show up in the
village with our own generator,
because you can't
trust the power supply,
and a projector and a white
sheet that becomes our screen.
And during the day,
we hand out pamphlets.
And then we start with singing
and dancing, because you know,
if you advertise germ
theory of disease,
not everybody shows up, right?
And so singing and
dancing, we've got a crowd.
And then, with the crowd
assembled-- and it's
pretty much the whole
village, because what else
is going on that
night, right, you
know, they're not watching
reruns of anything,
because there's no
TVs, right, and so we
got the attention of the
whole village-- we hook up
a microscope to that projector.
And we show them a
drop of the water
they've been drinking
for generations.
And we don't have
to check in advance.
It is alive with small animals.
It is really scary to see
your filthy water in that way.
And then, we go to some local
supplier of the safe water,
and we put a drop of that on it.
And it's not always
perfect, by the way.
But it's always way,
way better than this
really scary looking
water with the animals
in it, very small animals.
And then we ask a
different question.
And the behavioral economists
call this choice architecture,
which is the ability to
frame the question in a way
that people make answers
that are true to their belief
system.
And so now they've
seen the unsafe water.
They've seen the safe water.
And we say, never mind your mom.
Your mom did the best she could.
We address them as parents.
And we say, OK, now that
you have seen it, now
that you have seen the water
in this new way, which water
do you want your
children to drink?
And if you can frame that
question in that way,
people will change.
People will give up a
little something else
in order to have the safe
water for their families.
And so to do that with
diet and exercise,
to do that with
planning for retirement
or saving for college or the
thousand other things, energy
usage, or recycling,
or other things,
that's a big thing
to crack the code on.
FREDERIK G. PFERDT: Right.
Thank you.
So we have a
microphone over here.
If you want to please
start lining up
and ask your questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
FREDERIK G. PFERDT: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I have a
question that's actually
kind of on the opposite
end of the spectrum of what
you've been talking about.
And that's being overwhelmed
by the opportunity
to be creative and
come up with ideas.
I think I speak for
a lot of people.
Perhaps I've just
been fortunate.
But in my role and
experience at Google,
I've been a lot of
situations where
there's support for
creativity and the opportunity
to create ideas creates just
an overwhelming set of options.
And teams can just
spin and spin and spin
coming up with ideas,
all of them great.
But you run out of time and
even energy to reduce them
to actual practicing get things
done from that perspective.
So curious as to
what your experience
in a place like the
d.school, where likely there
is a lot of that going on,
is how do you stop that,
and how do you just move forward
with an idea or a select set
of ideas and get them working?
TOM KELLEY: Right.
So I totally believe you that
that's a problem at Google.
And I'm going to go
on record and say
in the other 99.9% of
client organizations I work
with, this is not their problem.
But nevertheless,
you have this issue.
And so what we would
recommend in a situation
like that is find the
quickest, cheapest way you
can prototype the
alternative ideas.
Because in the
prototype, you kind of
bring them to life
a little more,
so that it gets just a
little more tangible in a way
that reasonable people-- that
would be customers, maybe--
could look at it and say, oh,
I would totally go for that
or, like, oh, no, I would
never use that, right?
And so if you have
lots of ideas but you
can prototype them all up
to a level in which you
can get good feedback from
it, then the kind of winners
will start to emerge.
DAVID KELLEY: And
you probably do that.
But the thing has
to do with empathy.
We really believe that
even at Google, you're
not deep enough
involved with the people
that you're trying
to make raving fans.
I mean, my experience
at the d.school--
you asked about the d.school.
I can tell you-- yeah,
there's tons of ideas.
There's so many ideas.
But we just keep going
deeper and deeper
with the people we care
about, with the extreme users,
with the central
personas, the stuff.
And it just seems that they
just more quickly resonate
with some things than
they do the others.
And then, in this
prototyping way,
like you take the
pulse news reader
or whatever, what those guys
did it at the d.school--
it's like the users will
take you in the right place.
I mean, you're trying
to go to a really
special place with
a group of people.
And we at the d.school
just double down
on trying to
understand them more.
Because we have a
tendency to go back
to our offices or our
teams and sit around
and talk to each other.
And so by being out there in
the messiness of people where
they're going to
use this it seems
like is the only
thing we really have.
TOM KELLEY: We're doing a lot
of work with open innovation out
in the world.
It's called OpenIDEO.
The current
challenge is actually
about creative confidence.
But we'll ask a question.
People submit ideas.
And then they participate.
The open innovation
community participates,
in evaluating the ideas.
And we've now worked
with companies.
There's other people unrelated
to us doing this internally,
where it's open
innovation, but it's
only open within the company in
which the collective community
of the company judges and says,
wow, we really like this idea.
So you've got more than
just what your boss likes.
You've got what the
whole community believes
has value for the future.
AUDIENCE: I was
just going to ask,
I think in "The Ten
Faces of Innovation"
you discussed the
group of, I think,
it was fifth graders that you
worked with, or five-year-olds.
I forget what the number was.
I was just wondering how
that's been going since then,
if that's something
you guys still use?
TOM KELLEY: So this is a
question about an old book.
Fifth graders we worked with.
Don't know.
But that prompts a story,
which is one of the favorites.
Of the 100 people
we interviewed,
there's this teacher,
teaches the fifth grade.
Her name is Marcy Barton.
And she has been
teaching for 42 years.
And so I'm sure you've had those
kind of teachers, 42 years in.
They developed their
syllabus 41 years ago.
And they've been in full
implementation/repetition mode
ever since.
And that doesn't
quite describe Marcy.
So Marcy comes to the d.school.
She comes to a two-day
program for educators.
And by the way, I
am going to sound
like a paid spokesperson
for the d.school.
I'm not a Stanford guy at all.
I'm a Berkeley guy, right?
But Marcy is an amazing person.
She comes to the d.school
for this two-day program.
And based on that two days,
she basically changes her life.
She reinvents her
curriculum from scratch
after that two-day seminar.
And she does all project-based
learning with her kids now.
And so instead of
standing at the board
and talking about
immigration in the New World,
she turns the desks upside
down and puts the kids inside
and wraps it with craft paper.
And now they're in
they're in the ship going
go into the New World.
And they write
their constitution
while they're in the ship.
And then, when they get there,
they use their math skills
and make a perfect scale
model of the community.
And everything is a project.
And her kids have
done remarkably well.
And Marcy, at one
point in the interview,
she says, my kids are
wonderfully more creative
and they're engaged.
And she says, and
write this down.
And I'm thinking, Marcy,
we're taping this interview.
But anyhow, she still
wants us to write.
And she says, and
tell those parents,
my kids do better on the
standardized tests, too.
She says, of course,
they do better
on the standardized tests.
She says, my kids are
engaged every single day
of the school year.
And so Marcy says,
in the interview,
this design thinking stuff
she picked up at the d.school,
she says, this is
the cornerstone
of my career and my life.
And so that's Marcy story.
But it's so ridiculously
unbelievable
that David and I had to take
three steps back and think, OK,
how are we going to
explain this to anybody?
So here's our theory.
There's an old saying, sometimes
attributed to Plutarch,
but there's another
possible source for it,
where someone once said
that education is not
the filling of a vessel,
it's the lighting
of a fire, which is
not entirely true.
Because in the
airline magazine, when
it says you can learn Mandarin
in five days, that is bull.
You cannot learn
Mandarin in five days.
And here's why.
Because it's the
filling of a vessel.
It's vocabulary.
It's grammar.
It's tonality.
It's really, really hard.
But with Marcy, at the d.school,
she didn't fill any vessels.
She lit a fire.
She had almost everything
she needed and just
had this one more spark
that set it all off.
And so, anyhow, my favorite
fifth grade teacher
in the world now, even though
we met fairly recently.
DAVID KELLEY: Yeah, I'll
talk to five-year-olds.
Because he didn't know if
it was five or fifth grade,
so he did fifth grade.
I'll talk to five-year-olds.
So one of the things
we really found out,
that was really interesting,
is that teachers never
have time to give
the same problem,
even if they're
project-based learning,
they don't have time to give
the same problem over again.
And It turns out that
there's so much learning
in becoming expert in
doing the same project over
and over again.
So you give them the project.
And then everybody in the class
comes up with their ideas.
And then you've learned so
much, you become more expert.
Because you have your ideas,
and you've worked on it.
And then, you have all of
the other ideas or something,
and then you do it again.
So we've been experimenting.
We experimented with that,
where the same project is
given three times.
And so I'll just tell you my
favorite kindergarten class.
And the problem we give them
is redesigning your bedroom.
Fairly vigorous, anyway.
So everybody comes back.
And they come back.
And they've got
their little models.
And they're made out of
pipe cleaners and pieces
of cardboard and stuff.
I want to make a
long story short.
This one little
girl has the design.
They said, what's this?
And she says, well, here is it.
So we had them do need
finding and all this stuff.
And she'd gone out.
And her bedroom had a
place for the family car
to pull next to her bed.
Because her need was, when
we come home late at night
and I'm asleep, Dad has to carry
me all the way from the garage
into the bed.
So in her design,
the door to the car
opens-- she had a little
thing-- and she rolls out
right out of the car
into the bed, right?
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID KELLEY: Anyway, so then
we do another round, another
around.
And by the end,
every kid-- that's
the killer app, right--
every kid's thing
has a place for the car to park
next to their particular bed.
[LAUGHTER]
FREDERIK G. PFERDT: Great.
More questions?
AUDIENCE: Was there
any difference
when you did the survey across
the different countries,
or that survey
you had mentioned,
in terms of culturally whether
the US or any one country
is really behind or
really ahead and what
the driver may have been?
TOM KELLEY: Sure.
You gotta look at
the whole survey.
I was interested in
the overall response.
But when you look at the
individual country responses,
it's fascinating.
Because, basically,
every country
thinks that they are the most
creative country in the world,
right, though no one
else thinks they are.
But the exception
to that is Japan.
Everybody thinks that
Japan is creative
except Japanese people.
And so there's just this weird
kind of asymmetry to the belief
systems from country to country.
But that gets at this very
central theme in our book,
which is that
creative confidence is
the combination of
the natural ability
to come up with breakthrough
ideas and the courage
to act on them.
And so I've spent a ton
of my life in Japan.
I think it's a tremendously
creative country.
And sometimes, in
modern Japan, people
don't have the courage
to stand up and say,
this is a good idea.
They feel like they
have to self-edit,
they can't express
their creativity.
And so, I think, a
huge opportunity there.
But, yeah, country
by country, it's
quite interesting
to see how they
see themselves so differently
than other countries see them.
DAVID KELLEY: And we do user
research all over the world
constantly.
And I mean, people
are completely
different in their desires.
So I remember.
a vacuum cleaner
company asked us
to design a world
vacuum cleaner,
like one vacuum cleaner that
they could sell everywhere
in the world.
And it was hilarious, because
you go around and talk
to people about
vacuum cleaners, you
realize just how different
the cultures are.
You know, there
are places in Asia
where they wanted a really
technical vacuum cleaner that
counted dust mites and was
quiet and small and stuff.
And people in the United States
want some big piece of metal
that makes a loud
sucking noise, right?
And so it was not possible to
do a world product, at least
in this, physical things.
You guys have a
better chance of that.
AUDIENCE: Have you
guys had any instances
where the design approach
didn't work or it failed?
And then, what did
you guys do about it?
TOM KELLEY: Sure.
Have we had failures?
Yeah, you bet we have.
I mean, this is the
essence of our approach.
If you're not
failing, wow, you're
just not taking any risks.
It's like, I want
to learn to ski,
but I never want to
fall down, right?
Good luck with that.
And so lots of
failures along the way.
We were just doing a social
innovation project in Ghana
that had to do with,
let's just call it,
sanitation issues so as not
to turn off the whole crowd.
But anyhow, the sanitation issue
is public sanitation issues.
And we had this idea
that we'd put up signs
all over the
community and that we
would draw maps of where the
big issues were by having people
call in and say, over there,
there's a problem, over there.
And so we put these signs up
all over the community, call in.
And we got zero phone calls.
I mean, well, in
fact, the phone rang.
But nobody was ever there.
It's like, what the heck?
I mean, how are we going to
get data this way, right?
And then, we were outsiders.
We didn't fully understand.
We hadn't done all of
the design research
we needed to understand the
community we were working in.
And it turns out--
I guess, this is
true in many parts of
Africa-- an incoming phone
call on your cellphone is free.
An outgoing phone call is
the one you pay for, right?
So nobody is going to
pay for a phone call
to tell you about
sanitation issues.
And so there is this
practice very common
in that part of the
world called flashing.
And flashing is when you
call someone just enough
to make their phone ring and
record your caller ID number,
and then you hang up.
And if they want to talk
to you-- in other words,
if they want to pay
for the phone call--
then they'll call you back.
And so we went and changed all
of the signs all over and said,
don't call this number,
flash this number.
And then, we got all
kinds of data, right?
But shame on us for not
having figured it out.
I mean, we could have
printed those signs once
instead of twice.
But we were naive just as that
outsider in the Indian village
didn't fully understand
all of the things that
were making those
family decisions.
We didn't understand
the local community
enough to get it
right the first time.
DAVID KELLEY: Let me go
on record as saying IDEO
doesn't fail at
the end very often.
In the beginning,
it's a technique.
At the end, we tend to--
TOM KELLEY: Well, there
was that whole phase called
pen-based computers, many of
you too young to remember.
But we and all of our
clients failed in that phase.
Nobody wanted those things.
DAVID KELLEY: Well, one
of my favorite discussions
about failure is about one of
my buddies named John Cassidy.
John Cassidy is a wonderful guy.
He teaches at the d.school now.
But he started a company
called Klutz Press.
You know, Klutz Press is books
that you see in toy stores
with stuff.
Well, his first
project was called
"Juggling for the
Complete Klutz."
And it's a long story.
And he thought he was in
the juggling business.
And he never came out with
a book for five more years.
But then he figured he
was in the book business,
and he's done very well.
But he was in the juggling
business when he started.
Anyway, I got this book.
I didn't know Cass at the time.
But seemed like a good
idea, you know, juggling.
I could impress the girls
at parties or something
if I could juggle.
And so I want to do that.
Well, the whole first half
of the book is about failing,
about dropping the
ball on the floor.
It's called the drop.
He does nothing in this
book but desensitize you
to the ball dropping
on the floor.
He has lots of ways to do that.
But the ball hitting the
floor is just not a big deal.
It's not something that your
brain is trying to prevent,
because it's so normal.
And so, then, when
that happens, it's
incredibly easy to
learn how to juggle,
because it's just not that
mechanically difficult.
But what's happening
is your brain's
constantly worried about
or trying to keep you
from dropping the
ball on the ground.
And so it's a great example
of how you can get over
that kind of fear that
you might make a mistake.
And then you can
accomplish things
that seem particularly
difficult.
TOM KELLEY: You know, a great
microculture in the world that
has got the right attitude about
failure is the gaming culture.
I mean, you think about
gaming, it's about failure.
I tell a story in the
book about my son Sean
who, Christmas Day a few
years back, got the Tony Hawk
skateboarding game.
And those of you who
have played it may know,
it's got a skateboard inside.
It's got a full-size
skateboard that you stand on.
And it controls the game.
And he's there in front of three
generations of Kelleys, right,
trying out his new game.
And on-screen, his avatar-- you
know, his character on-screen,
is smashing into the wall,
like, a couple of hundred times.
And unlike some
other video games,
he's also physically falling
off of the skateboard
and nearly breaking
the glass coffee table
and stuff like that.
And I'm sitting there watching
him for, like, half an hour.
And it suddenly occurs to
me, this is amazing, right?
I mean, he's got the whole
family watching him fail time
after time after
time, and he's not
the tiniest bit embarrassed.
So how is it that in
the gaming culture,
you have this what
Jane McGonigal calls
urgent optimism.
It's like, OK, that failed.
Better try again, as
opposed to, in real life,
where you say, oh, that failed.
I'm marked for life, right?
And so, if we can
have a little bit more
of the gaming culture, the best
parts of the gaming culture,
out here in the physical world,
that would be a good thing.
FREDERIK G. PFERDT: Great.
I think that's a
great note to end on,
to encourage everybody
over the weekend at least
to try a game--
[LAUGHTER]
FREDERIK G. PFERDT:
--fail a couple of times,
even if it's juggling.
We have books which
David and Tom might
sign the back for
a special price.
And thanks,
everybody, for coming.
And have a great weekend.
[APPLAUSE]
TOM KELLEY: All right.
[MUSIC PLAYING]